hello and welcome to another Python
mathematics and stock indicators
tutorial video this video we're going to
be discussing center of gravity but
actually the indicator center of gravity
now if you look up the formula for this
you're gonna get something pretty
similar to this although this one's
actually incorrect because it doesn't
have the negative sign in front of it
you are supposed to get a negative sign
there so you reverse or you kind of flip
the chart itself and I'll show you what
I mean by that in a minute
so the center of gravity indicator
originates from this article by John F
Ehlers and the idea of it is to exhibit
really no lag at all and that's kind of
what it's known for is it's an indicator
that really has no lag now this is the
calculation it's hopefully a little bit
easier to understand but then if you
still don't get it when we go to program
it I think it'll be really quite simple
so the calculation is you know the idea
of it is really I would ignore this part
and just say like it's N times price or
n times price n right and so generally
you might have ten days or something
like that is usually what you're going
to use so if it's ten days and n is ten
then it's ten times price number ten
right and ten being ten days ago not you
know yesterday or whatever so then with
that you would do one through ten just
like that and then you divide it by the
price in that again so and then don't
forget the the negation of the entire
thing so it actually works out the way
that we want it to so with that let's go
ahead and see some examples of what
happens when you chart this so let me go
ahead and pull it up the first one we
can look at we'll look at eBay and so
here's an example of center of gravity
for eBay it's on the bottom indicator
there right here and so as you can see
there's very little to no lag at all and
if anything it's actually a leading
indicator in many instances here
so a good example of when it's actually
a leading indicator would be right here
where I mean it hits the absolute bottom
possibly here you would think but
actually the real absolute bottom is
here but it's already begun moving up as
far as the center of gravity was
concerned and sure enough it is and then
you can see just every time it comes
down I mean this has it just boom like
right right on so it's actually pretty
cool I mean obviously there's gonna be
times where it's not as that perfect I
don't find a time where there's a lot of
fluctuations that I could show that like
here for it would be an example where
it's like this is it saying the peak is
here and then it starts going down but
it's missing it so it went up but for
any of these like long rides you know
like this one was a really good one this
one here was also where it said the peak
or the bottom was here you know and it
goes up so kind of an interesting
indicator it's a lot like you'll see
that it follows the RSI pretty well but
where the RSI says hey this is like
where the RSI says hey if it gets below
30 that's oversold the center of gravity
is telling you know that's like where
the where it wants to be right now and
then when it starts coming up then then
you're interested you know so they do
Ted there they are different for sure
but you'll see that they follow very
similar paths quite often so it would be
a good it's kind of a good combination
to use with RSI in my opinion because
when they are following the same path
you could ignore it and then when
they're not then you might want to
listen to the RSI at least so with that
that's the center gravity indicator a
lot of times you'll see it with the
bands and we might end up doing one with
the bands on the price eventually but
for now like this is the official one
you there's also like the center of
gravity bands that you can put but
really that's mostly kind of like a
combination of the center of gravity
plus Bollinger Bands like the same kind
of theory going into those so we can
eventually do that we have done
Bollinger Bands and you could do you
just apply Bollinger Bands to this and
then you normalize it by putting it on
here usually like a percent change
change would do it and there's also a
couple other ways that you can do it
like with logarithm and stuff but anyway
we might get to that eventually but this
is just the simple center of gravity so
with that in the next video what we're
gonna be talking about is actually how
to program that within Python and then
in the next video we'll actually chart
it up just like this and you guys can
play with it yourself so as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support and subscriptions and until the
next video